and finally new rule the Pennsylvania
teenager who faces up to two years in
jail for disrespecting this statue of
Jesus must show us he's really got balls
and tried with a statue of Mohammed oh
don't [ __ ] start with me if it's
gonna get worse right now actually
that's a trick question because there
are no statues of Muhammad because if
you made one there'd be a fatwa and
you'd wind up dead now folks I know as
difficult as it is to face this issue it
is important for us as Americans to
remember what we stand for of all the
iconic American images in our history
there's no picture that makes my heart
swell with patriotism quite like this
one because this kid is not going to get
killed for this he's not even going to
jail yes there's some local dumbass DEA
trying to throw the book at him but come
on he's a kid he's just doing what kids
do making Jesus blow them USA USA USA it
may not be in good taste I certainly
don't condone this type of behavior
praying I mean
but it speaks volumes about why liberal
Western culture is not just different
it's better
President Obama keeps insisting that
Isis is not Islamic well maybe they
don't practice the Muslim faith the same
way he does but if vast numbers of
Muslims across the world believe and
they do that humans deserve to die for
merely holding a different idea or
drawing a cartoon or writing a book or
eloping with the wrong person not only
does the Muslim world have something in
common with Isis it has too much in
common with Isis there's so much talk
you can claw applaud there's so much
talk about wiping out Isis you can't not
with bombs you can only expose that
something is a bad idea like extended
warranties cultures are different it's
okay to judge that rule of law isn't
just different than theocracy it's
better if you don't see that you're
either a religious fanatic or a
masochist but one thing you are
certainly not is a liberal to count
yourself as a liberal you have to stand
up for liberal principles free speech
separation of church and state
freedom to practice any religion or no
religion without the threat of violence
respect respect for minorities including
homosexuals equality for women it's it
amazes me how here in America we go nuts
over the tiniest violations of these
values while gross atrocities are
ignored across the world Jonah Hill
yells suck my dick [ __ ] at the
paparazzi and an entire nation goes into
Twitter outraged until he is forced to
perform that most abasing of acts the
talkshow apology tour meanwhile in 10
countries actually sucking a dick can
get you stoned and not in a good way we
hear a lot about the Republican war on
women it's not cool Rush Limbaugh called
somebody a [ __ ] okay but Saudi women
can't vote or drive or hold a job or
leave the house without a man
overwhelming majorities in every Muslim
country say a wife is always obliged to
obey her husband that all seems like a
bigger issue than a van Jellicle
Christian bakeries refusing to make gay
wedding cakes
91% of Egyptian women have had their
clitoris is forcibly removed
98% of Somalian women have ayaan Hirsi
Ali grew up in Somalia and is one of
them she was scheduled to speak at Yale
last week but the school's atheist
organization my people complain that she
quote did not represent too totality of
the ex Muslim experience meaning what
the women who like mutilation your
atheists you should be attacking
religion not siding with the people who
hold women down and violate them which
apparently you will defend in the name
of multiculturalism and then lose your
[ __ ] when someone refers to Chaz Bono by
the wrong pronoun
Donald sterling isn't allowed to own a
team because he told his mistress not to
post pictures with black guys okay but
if we're giving no quarter to
intolerance
shouldn't we be starting with the
mutilators and the honor killers or will
that divert us from the real problem
that when Mel Gibson drinks he calls
women sugar tits